well we can stick with looking ahead to
Russia soon acts economic update on
Wednesday jobs jobs jobs according to
Matt Hancock
we're joined now from sky by a man with
a list of demands for the Chancellor the
SMPS Westminster leader in black votes
thank you for being on the show what is
it that you are hoping to see from the
transfer next week well there's a
five-point plan that we have Sophie so
we're asking for a significant
investment from the government into the
economy we as politicians as governments
we crash the economy in order to see
people's health we've got a
responsibility to invest for recovery to
invest to see jobs coming back and I'm
asking that the Chancellor it takes
similar measures to what we saw in
Germany but there's been a 4% of GDP
investment that would mean for the UK
about 80 billion pounds to kick-start
the economy we have to give people hope
secondly we need to see the devolution
of powers to Scotland so that we have
the powers to deal with the virus that
we need here in Scotland we also need to
extend the fungal scheme for many of the
reasons that have been in the package
that you just had there many businesses
are going to see a difficult period
ahead of them and we need to support
businesses through that hospitality and
tourism sector and for example so the
funnel scheme must have been in place
for those that need it and it must be
done on the basis of a four-nation
approach to that we also need to see
investment to deal with child poverty
and that backhauls that we've had from
the resolution foundation for example
for a 20 point increase in the child
element of universal credit and working
tax credits and then finally to see a
reduction in dat for the fixed period in
order to again click start the economy
but also it's a company that our two
pence reduction in national insurance
contributions to protect jobs so we
really need a robust package to give
confidence to businesses to individuals
and communities the government will play
its part to kick-start the economy we
need to recognize the scale of the
challenge the House of Commons library
has indicated the potential increase in
unemployment to 3.8 million that is a
price which is not worth paying for a
crisis that's not the fault of
individuals or businesses government has
to show leadership in it for me see so
one final point Sophie what we saw last
week from the prime minister was a
missed opportunity and if we can
contrast what's happened
quantities and rightly there's been a
hundred billion investment through the
Bank of England in the month of June we
need to have this same skill of evidence
of action from the government and fiscal
measures to match what we've done in the
mandatory field okay well you're pretty
fully set out there at what you're
hoping to see we'll find out on
Wednesday if any of your demands have
been met just to pick up on what you
were saying there about devolution
Nicola Sturgeon saying that she was
underwhelmed by some of the
infrastructure spending the Prime
Minister pledged this week because it
didn't include any Barnett money for
Scotland now some people might be
thinking that you're effectively asking
for more money more investment to deal
with coronavirus but at the same time at
having a more stringent knock down in
Scotland which could exacerbate the
economic hit further I mean isn't that
just kind of by asking first you know
more money but also a longer lock down
is that not just having a cake and
eating it no it's not is a very exciting
the responsibilities of leadership and
we can see that affected and they Sunday
Times Paul today are fantastic reaching
for the First Minister plus 60 minus 39
for Boris Johnson that I think people
are reflecting on the kind of measures
that the Scottish government have taken
and frankly when we look at the evidence
and you see the prevalence rate of the
riders it's a fifth at the rate in
Scotland that it is in England and I
think that caution that we have had in
Scotland has been rewarded by that
improve performance but I have to say
that the point I guess we're saying that
if you have a more cautious lock down
than the economic hit will be bigger and
yet you can ask the more money to deal
with it well I would suggest that if we
have you second we've then the economic
hit would be even more damaging so what
we're trying to do is to protect the
interests of businesses protect public
health but make sure that we can come
out of this but we need the flexibility
to do so and I think the whole point
about what we see from devolution is
that we don't have the powers to deal
with the corvid crisis the way that we
should we want to make sure that we can
protect people in our industries in the
tourism sector and the hospitality
sector and if the government is going to
take away that job retention program in
October we need to make sure that we can
support people here then I think rightly
people in Scotland are contrasting the
leadership of our First Minister and
Boris Johnson who seems to be bobbing
his way through this crisis
now you were saying there that Scotland
has got relatively low infection rates
and yesterday Scotland didn't record any
new deaths from coronavirus only 11 new
cases if you continue to suppress the
virus in Scotland would it be a good
idea to actually stop people traveling
from England or Wales to Scotland to try
and slow the spread but of course we
don't want to stop people traveling we
want to make sure that we can open up as
much as we can but I think it is fair to
say that there was a degree of
frustration that we haven't had the
conversations with all four governments
in the United Kingdom when it comes to
the quarantine regulations for example
when those coming into the United
Kingdom women that the fact is as I've
highlighted you've conceded this
prevalence rate here is much lower so we
need to look at those coming in here and
the kind of risks that are there but any
decision that will be taken by the
Scottish Government will be based on the
scientific advice that we get and then
keeping people safe but let me say that
Scotland is a welcoming country of
course we want to welcome people here
are tools of Industry is is important to
us as vital but it's about taking the
right decisions at the right time based
on the scientific evidence so just to be
clear there and if the scientists are
biting this course your comments say
that actually you would be keeping
people safer if you close the border you
do it well I don't think we should be
looking at em what to the language about
causing the border that I checked so
they couldn't put in place this is about
keeping people safe and I have to say
anything from England could be forced to
quarantine then would that be a fair
away well the simple fact of the matter
is we have had reasonable success and
driving down the incidence of the virus
over the course of the last few months
has been hard one and of course we have
to take the appropriate measures to make
sure that we can continue to see that
but we'll do that in the respectful way
based on the evidence that we see and of
course we're always trying to do things
in cooperation with other parts of the
United Kingdom okay now pubs in England
open their doors yesterday it was
interesting recent reports and research
in this interview saying the pub owners
on the English side of the border had
said that up to a third of their
bookings are actually from Scottish
people travelling there are you worried
about Scott's going to drink and pubs in
England and then coming back but we are
what we did over the course of the last
couple of days as we've changed the
guidance for people
people weren't able to travel any more
than five miles that's change that
people can travel I'd simply say to
everybody whether you're in Scotland
open wheels and all that I am
responsibility to make sure that we're
doing what we can to drive the virus
down yes if people want to go to pubs
were permitted to do so but please
ensure that he enforced the rules on
social distancing and a lot of their own
rules that are there I think everyone's
got a responsibility to be even a
responsible manner I understand that
people want to go out and of course we
aren't going to be in the situation of
beer gardens and spot where they're
going to be open but what we are doing
is that we're doing this in a cautious
way on an evidence-based approach to
make sure that we keep people see if
that's rightly we take off some of the
restrictions of people what does he come
off okay thank you so much for being on
the program today thank you